[Music]
the job of a data scientist is to make
sense of information what does data tell
are there any patterns
and more importantly can it help us
forecast the future but what if we need
to predict the future every day every
hour or minutes and do that for
thousands of people simultaneously say
predict the taxi arrival time there's
one specific role that builds a bridge
between data science and its practical
counterpart machine learning
meet the machine learning engineer
let's imagine we have a product team
that builds a ride-hailing app what we
want is an algorithm that will
accurately predict pickup time for the
customer we can calculate pickup time
based on distance and average time
without machine learning using a simple
rule-based system but there are plenty
of variables that may skew the results
rainfalls or blizzards traffic
congestion
and road incidents all affect the
arrival time with a rule-based system a
software engineer would have to consider
all possible factors and write code for
them
there are so many of those and there's
no way to write rules for everything
then how can an ml engineer help they
can build a model that learns all the
possible relations between data by
itself and then gives us a more accurate
prediction if we support it with the
necessary data that said let's talk
about ml engineers responsibilities
so an ml engineer will start with
choosing and preparing data let's assume
that there are several variables we need
to calculate pickup time the distance
from the customer to the driver speed
weather and traffic congestion to name a
few all of these can become features
data attributes a model uses to give us
prediction results to get this data an
ml engineer will have to analyze
historical records on previous pickups
that contain those variables choosing
the right data and consolidating it is
the first step in preparation then the
ml engineer would clean the errors from
the data fill in the missing entries and
transform records into a single format
once the data is ready an ml engineer
needs to choose an algorithm that would
fit the task
the choice depends on the type of data
expected predictive accuracy and how
resource intensive the model is
you may need deep neural networks to
process images and videos with 98
accuracy but training them would require
renting clusters of gpus and running
those models in production may require
specific ai optimized processing units
but sometimes good old decision trees
would be enough
the ml engineer would experiment with
several models and a subset of data to
find the one that fits the task to start
with model training
during the training process a model will
learn to make predictions by finding
patterns in the training data set you
also need a testing set of historical
data to evaluate whether the model gives
accurate forecasts if it passes the test
congratulations we have a model that can
make predictions but the model isn't a
part of our product and our customers
can't use it yet so now an ml engineer
comes to productionalizing the model and
its deployment
here is our taxi application or in this
case two client applications used by
drivers and customers and our server
where all the back end logic sits now we
need to deploy the model machine
learning models are usually deployed as
a microservice an isolated container
where the code has all the dependencies
and can perform as a standalone unit so
an ml engineer wraps up the model into a
container and deploys it on the server
then he or she needs to connect the
model to data sources
the applications will handle some part
of the data like driver and customer
geolocation current speed of the car and
so on we'll also need extra data like
traffic incidents jams or whether that
comes from a separate database from this
point the model can consume the required
data calculate a prediction and send it
back to the customer but here is another
problem
remember we tested the model on
historical data but how well does it
work in real life conditions
you need to track its performance and
this is one of the main concerns of a
machine learning engineer
model performance monitoring and
evaluation
let's say the model predicted a taxi
would arrive in 14 minutes while it
actually took 20 minutes
to capture this an ml engineer would set
up monitoring infrastructure to compare
real world data to the model's
predictions to understand its accuracy
and how it changes over time
monitoring systems provide ml engineers
with necessary data to make a decision
whether the model performs well and if
it needs retraining so what is that
as world conditions are changing the
model can require new data
say a large part of a major city highway
was closed for reconstruction which made
drivers reach their destinations later
the model started predicting a pickup
time less accurately because it was
trained on outdated data and if the ml
engineer has monitoring systems set
right they will show this drift such
changes are a prerequisite for training
a new model with fresh data since the
world conditions may change daily
retraining often becomes a daily task
for a machine learning engineer so it
makes sense to automate this process
as you can see the ml engineer is
generally responsible for
well the whole machine learning part of
the product starting from data analysis
to the moment the model is trained and
launched in production
so what would the typical background and
skill set of an ml engineer look like
first it's statistics data analysis and
applied mathematics as ml engineers
curate features and prepare data the
fundamentals are critical
as you probably guessed these
specialists must also know existing
machine learning algorithms and common
architectures decision trees support
vector machines naive bayes deep
learning networks are a few popular
algorithms used in ml applications
to train those models engineers have to
be familiar with common tools python is
the main programming language used in
data science ml engineers may also be
proficient in r to explore and visualize
data similar to software engineering ml
has a number of frameworks and libraries
that specialists use to streamline their
work one of the main ones is
scikit-learn which is a python based
library featuring a variety of machine
learning algorithms as deep learning
becomes a universal answer to any ml
problem it has its own library
tensorflow but what about skills
required for production engineering
normally ml engineers are required to
know high performance languages like
java and c plus to run models on the
server if they work with big data
architectures ml engineers must be
familiar with distributed computing
frameworks like hadoop and data
processing tools like apache spark and
if the product actively uses deep
learning the engineer may need to know
how to configure parallel gpu computing
platforms such as nvidia cuda
so where do machine learning engineers
come from obviously you'd expect them to
have a computer science education some
engineers transition from software
development while others start with data
science and analytics and then acquire
engineering skills
but this set of skills sounds like a
data scientist right then what's the
difference between them and when
specifically should you hire an ml
engineer the production part is what can
draw the line between data scientists
and machine learning engineers the
latter definitely train launch and
maintain ml models data scientists may
not do that what about data engineers
the responsibilities of a machine
learning engineer will also overlap with
that of a data engineer a specific tech
professional that focuses on
transferring data from one system to
another managing databases and working
with data transformation tools ml
engineers and data engineers often
cooperate in running data
infrastructures that support machine
learning back to our example
an ml engineer is likely to define
specifications for a database to keep
information on traffic incidents jams or
weather in turn data engineers can use
these specifications to upload data to a
database and connect it with the model
and there you have it
if you're aiming at running machine
learning models in production you're
looking for an ml engineer to set up
data infrastructure and databases you'd
look for a data engineer
and if you need deep data research and
analysis without necessarily running
machine learning
you should consider data scientists
of course it's hard to draw clear lines
to separate these three roles but this
distinction should make things a bit
easier for you